I I think so much of this fear the left
has is fake is like it's real fear but
the cause of his fake so I'll give I'll
tell you guys many of you may have heard
the story but we'll talk about it now so
uh
not this past weekend the weekend before
I go and skate in DC at Freedom Plaza
nothing happens just literally skate
around hang out apparently some like
woke crew got angry and started sending
messages throughout the skate Community
about how I was brought there by some
pros I wasn't I went there got there
before they were there and it's like of
course I know they are they're famous
Pro skaters and uh so I was like oh wow
look you know Pro skaters and uh so
apparently it was a big deal and their
messages being sent around I'm getting
texts from like pros they're like yo
like it's a lot of flat going on like
people are mad that you were there and
I'm like nobody said anything to me they
were posting in forums lies saying like
everybody stand on the other side of the
park I was sitting alongside 15 other
people we were chilling there's a dog
and dog pissed on the ground we're out
skating and these things happen
and so I'm like my guys it's not real we
go skate all over the place you know
what I own the only thing I see
we went to the opening the hair to
Hagerstown Skate Park Maryland fist
bumps high fives people were like whoa
oh crap yo Tim cool to see you let's
let's Skate we went up to one indoor
skate park in Altoona Pennsylvania and
we I walk in and what do I hear they're
coming for your income tax and I'm like
these guys watching things I can verify
I was there that day it was cool yeah
yeah we hung out and the dudes were like
oh wow cool and cool to see you and they
were like dude skateboarders are like
anti-establishment people
but all of a sudden now I got these
industry people being like bro we're
taking a lot of heat like people are
really freaking out about what's going
on and I said no they aren't dude this
is not true and they were like well look
man like it's getting bad and then I
said I'm gonna go back on Saturday I'm
gonna tell everybody to be there and I'm
telling you nothing's gonna happen and
what happened a bunch of people showed
up we skated we hung out people took
pictures I gave out skateboards locals
gave me fist bumps
and we had good time then someone told
us about this uh little spot called the
Big Board in DC that defied the
lockdowns and they were like you should
go eat there because they told you know
mural Bowser to Fu when she was trying
to lock everything down and then so then
I said to everybody okay that's where
we're going and we packed the place it
was just like every table filled this
whole venue that's what it's all about
not only did we prove that the fear
these people in skateboarding had over
oh no everyone's going to be mad you're
there oh we're not true never happened
it was a lie to scare you into not
speaking up and being yourself and I had
no problem showing up skating around and
bringing Taylor Silverman and Taylor of
course is the one who called out
biological males competing against
females against her and she gets tons of
threats and hate and we announce will be
in a Public Square
by ourselves well you know with our fans
or whatever and our friends but like
skating around any one of these whack
jobs could have come up to us and done
anything they wanted nothing happened
not a single hater showed up no violence
nothing but happiness and high fives and
then
with that Gathering and people met each
other and talked to each other hung out
and laughed and had a good time we also
told everybody to go and hang out at the
Big Board in DC
to support businesses that stood up for
what they believed in creating nothing
but massive positivity without a modicum
of hate or resistance people need to
stop believing the lies the woke people
are like we'll cancel you what's the
worst that's going to happen what's the
worst gonna happen yeah
yeah that's why I want to know what the
money is behind groups like antifa
because I don't think it's organic I
don't think it's really there I think
you have to have some type of funding or
push to get you don't think so I don't
think you need funding to get a bunch of
unemployed whack jobs to go be whack
jobs you know you need some because
organizational power is tough but it
shows you that if there's nothing to
Target there's nothing to Target if I
announced we were doing a legitimate
event speakers tents and everything they
could stop that they'd call the city
they'd make complaints but when I said
I'm just going to be standing there not
a single hater showed up not a single
complaint was made
we skated around
did some tricks I did a kind of a bunk
forward flip because it was like windy
and cold someone filmed it so they put
up a video on Instagram actually let me
shout the dude on Instagram I think I
have it on my phone that's pretty cool
were you still gonna do a skate Channel
I remember yeah we talked about it
we're working on it let me uh well it
just it just disappeared do you have
this kind of feeling of community uh
where you're from do you do and do you
think there's a way to help facilitate
all that
um I think everybody has their own
talents so where I'm from I don't really
feel the I don't really feel it much
anywhere I mean there's not many people
working towards that solution
um I want to do a shout out to uh black
Pegasus who's A hip-hop artist out of
Colorado
this Christmas he went around to
Christmas malls and he's been practicing
freestyling him and his partner partner
Don so they walk up to random people
and they just say hey how you doing you
wanna of candy cane they take a candy
cane out there's like a little five
dollar bill on it and then they say give
me three words I'm gonna wrap a song for
you just out of the blue and then they
wrap a song for them and then sometimes
they give them like a stack of ones or
something like that but that's
connecting to people completely
apolitical but I think I believe
everybody has their own talent to do
that maybe you so maybe you play music
um whatever that is that's the answer to
me to break away from from what we're
seeing right the ballistic boy on
Instagram Everybody follow the ballistic
boy he produced a video from the from
the quote unquote unevent we did and
there's just happy people standing
around taking pictures people skating
and doing tricks fist bumps no hate and
that that was the privilege point that I
could show up in public with a week's
lead time everybody can know nothing
bad's gonna happen I got mixed feelings
about it because it feels like going
into a bear's den and then standing
there and being like see the bear didn't
attack me I'm fine but like it's not I
don't think it's sustainable what better
though that's the point there was no
bear there you're calling it a bear's
den and I'm like bro we're gonna go in
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna turn the flashlight and show
you there's not a problem not
embarrassment but it's like saying hey
all bears I'm gonna be here on this time
in this day they're not bears and you
shouldn't live I mean some of them
pretty chunky but they don't move like
Bears okay and what happens can a
squirrel attack you and bite you all
these things yes I give you baby do you
want to you know run into a a cave full
of angry rabbit squirrels you don't but
you know what happens when you when you
yell around squirrels they run away yeah
right I get it's just that I don't know
if it's it's sustainable to dox yourself
and other people a week beforehand to
have a million people providing our
assassination coordinates yeah exactly
like if we did that every week for 10
years I would imagine one of those weeks
something bad could it's just not a
sustainable price maybe but when we were
in Nashville and we wanted to go play at
John Rich's Honky Tonk and the death
threats came in they said we can't do it
and then I said I don't care I'll do it
anyway nothing's gonna happen and they
were like but there are people here if
something does happen there's kids we
could get hurt I said okay fine you know
it's like your Venue I did this to prove
that point these people are all talk all
bark no bite I used to notice that in La
too like I was like I'm tired of this
people they would say in L.A people are
fake and I knew they weren't so I had to
get through these people I just decided
let's get rid of the pretense go
straight eye contact eye contact every
human I would meet I would talk to them
like this as if they were my best friend
and people would respond as if they were
my best friend when you give them that
energy so I think you can get through to
every human it was a hundred percent it
would work 100 of the time and then but
what I realized is you can't be friends
with everybody you got about 60 people
after that it starts to drive you insane
so you shouldn't Live Your Life In Fear
like I refuse to do that and you know
you talked about how Tim's you know
docson comes up I mean people know where
we live right the address here has been
leaked many times but you know we've
been swatted many times so they already
know so what what's stopping them from
from doing anything I mean it's really
based on your approach as a human being
and how you interact and what you bring
into your own life and I just refuse to
be in that kind of fear mindset myself I
agree I don't want to live in fear I
don't but I don't think it just it
doesn't mean if you decide not to do
certain things it doesn't mean that
you're it's because you're afraid or a
coward like some things technically or
mathematically are not a good function
that you want to be involved with yeah
that doesn't mean that you're afraid
you're just doing the math looking at
the odds looking at the risk but if they
could get you there they could get you
here right because they know I'll give
you an example though of Tim you know
showing the boundaries remember when
Andy know in my opinion unnecessarily
put himself Undercover the second time
he had already came out with his book on
antifa that he went undercover again and
you guys covered it remember and Tim I
believe and I agreed with this said that
was an unnecessary risk so I think you
know you guys did the risk I think you
have a great point you got to look at
the risk reward I don't think Tim's
gonna do it every week but uh the
courage you've got to show some courage
I think for everybody watching this this
isn't just for Tim or Ian or anybody
else we've all got to have courage
um you know the history of this country
is founded on people with courage I mean
they what tried to tax T three cents you
know a pound of tea and they went nuts I
don't want you know I want peacefulness
but you have to have courage to stand up
for and courage can be just like what
we're doing not just talking I respect
and you know tremendously and I think
what he did was tremendously Brave yeah
I just felt that like the risk versus
reward was extremely high risk with
really low reward it was a local Fringe
antifa meeting it wasn't a big prominent
one it was like a handful of just
lunatics and then he went right into the
middle of their group
what we were doing was going to a place
I had already been
and had no issues at telling my friends
to show up there we can advance
and then showing up
and nothing happened I didn't say like
I'm gonna go find you know antifa's
house and go inside of it and uh you
know and we talked you know Andy and I
talked about it I apologize for being
crass and everything but I still think
it was unnecessary risk I respect him
wanting to cover the stuff and get more
information I do I understand it but we
were basically saying hey we skate we're
allowed to be here I live here I live in
this area I'm gonna skate here and I
proved that a lot of this is just
nonsense
and I gotta be honest I'm willing to bet
if Andy Noe announced he was going to be
at Freedom Plaza nobody would have shown
up to harass him it would not have
happened yeah it does seem like it's
more about the events it's more about
the uh like the intentions that are
being blockaded and and stressed not the
people themselves it's almost irrelevant
so what people are why do you think it
was different with the Nashville show
where there was someone else owned the
venue oh so it's still gone so they they
put pressure on the venue owners or
whoever the business is well John Rich
owned it and oh is it his okay it was
his place and he said why don't we go
Jam I said let's do it and we announced
it and then they got some suspicious
calls a guy showed up some other stuff
happened and he was like we can't do it
it's it it's this is this is the problem
they can use this as an attack Vector
they can't use it against me right it
might work against your traditional
run-of-the-mill person who's like look
I can't risk the security stuff my
attitude is like dude
I'm not the one
you know when when Nancy goes around
throwing Molotov cocktails I'm throwing
it through it that's not on me and you
can't put that on me if I'm going to
exist and live in the space I will do it
and if a crazy person is crazy that's
something for the government for the
police to deal with and then to the
extent that we have to defend ourselves
we will too so when we open our Cafe I'm
not going to put up signs in the window
saying please don't hurt us I'm going to
put signs in the window saying America
First yeah don't tread on me and
everyone's gonna know exactly who we are
and what we believe and maybe they'll
want to say nasty things about us don't
know don't care I'm not no one no
external factor is going to come in and
look
I didn't run a business during the
lockdowns but I absolutely would have
been one of the businesses saying Fu to
the machine just like the big board did
in in DC shout out to them again because
that's the story I guess they said no
way we're not shutting down I've done
the same thing and see here's the thing
it's easy for me to say because we've
got we've got funds
for these smaller businesses that
actually did it that shows you who's got
balls these guys do
uh big board by the way open till
midnight if you guys want to get in
there and get something if you're in DC
that's where you should be eating
because I gotta the wings were good I
got the Kung Pao Wings it was really
good yeah it was really really good
actually I'm hungry again
this is like once as you get more famous
as an Entertainer your your role becomes
like Annie knows situation he used to be
able to go under under cover because no
one knew who he was now he's he's
serving a different function but you're
right that we need to be brave but like
I used to do Gatherings and meetups and
events out in the open we'd all be like
hey on the 7th of July we're all going
to meet in Washington Square Park we get
like 50 people would go we'd all have
cameras with I never thought in my mind
like danger that never crossed my mind
but I was an unknown person at that time
I don't know if it matters how famous
you are
um I don't know I was thinking as well
it's also like if they know like Fox is
going to be there if they know CNN's
going to be there then they're more
likely to go out and and do these things
in protests and create like counter
protests and everything like that but if
it's just Tim going to go hang out I
don't think that they're gonna you know
they're not gonna show up we announced
uh you know Phil was an to be there
Libby Evans was there Taylor silver was
there like she moved didn't she did she
move from New York I think I saw uh yeah
she did because every time she comes on
I'm like how are you in New York with
you know things are getting serious
where did she move to again I don't know
okay
but uh yeah she Libby went went rural
wow no I think the way we described it
was if you create an event they'll
attack the venue they'll use the
government against you if you just make
it an event there's literally nothing
they can do right because if they show
up to protest they'll be like oh you
guys are going to protest here I'll go
skate across the street yeah protest
what exactly you might be on to
something do you think that would work
in Portland yes wow you might be you
might be onto something Portland well I
mean that's isn't that the heart or
wherever the real City this is basically
what they do yeah they March around
randomly totally and so like what are
the cops gonna do you can't stand here
okay we'll stand over there yeah so
obviously though like Patriot pair Mark
Patriot prayer marches around they fight
with them you know but my thing is like
I didn't set up an event to protest
anything yeah just declare anything
exactly I'm going to be here and I'm
going to assert cultural presence in the
space and then we gave out like 30 or
some odd boards and uh I told I told
these guys I will flood the DC Metro
with a thousand free skateboards I will
give every single little kid in this in
this metro area a free skateboard every
skating kid and then every little kid
will be riding around on a step on step
and find out board and all the people
can cry about it and then you know we
can do because we're opening this Cafe
second floor is going to be uh skate and
game shop we will sell our boards at
dirt prices
cost
and you know I know a lot of people are
you know that's bad for other shops or
whatever yeah but the other shops are
woke
there's like there's like one or two
other shops and I don't hear good things
about them
and so I'm like well you know what if
these are the people who ride for these
shops
that I hope they go to business
and that's competition baby you get woke
you go broke I'll open up my shop we'll
sell all of our stuff as dirt cheap as
possible
and then let's see how long these well
these Workshops can last true let's
compete are you gonna sell wheels and
trucks too oh of course yeah everything
well we're not going to make our own
making our own wheels is actually pretty
easy because it's all like you find a
company that does urethane and then you
get it special formula formula and uh
and and labeling skate decks are
relatively similar you find a company
you find the shape and the sizes you
want then you get the graphics put on
them
so we'll have all our own stuff but
we'll probably just sell your your
typical skate stuff and we'll sell it
for dirt we'll sell it at cost
we'll pass those savings on to the
regular people now Distributors are
going to get mad a lot of these
warehouses might refuse a service being
like no because you're gonna You're
Gonna Hurt our other business
because if shops go out of business
because they're only buying for you then
we lose sales and things like that I've
seen it happen yeah what I noticed that
when you look at around at stores you'll
never see like well I can't say never
but like a discrepancy in the cost of an
item from Target to Walmart to Mom and
Pop like not that much or maybe I'm
wrong about that but are there like
cabals that are price fixing behind the
scenes like Hasbro it's about price
fixing it's like if there are 10 skate
shops in one area
and one of them goes to the warehouse
and you know and they're all buying from
the same Distributors a big Warehouse
that has everything and then they sell
to the shops they might not do it the
same way anymore now with the internet
and Amazon and all this stuff but if one
of these shops starts selling boards for
a dollar over cost compared to like five
dollars over cost the other shops do the
other shops start being unable to
compete start buying less from the
warehouse complain to the warehouse
being like yeah this one Shop's just
gutting us then they'll say we cut off
one shop or we lose five customers
it's not necessarily price fixing but I
don't know it might be illegal I've
heard stories you know
but uh I'm down we'll see what we can do
I think that's the answer what you're
doing right there yeah it's literally
like just making you know this the
Marxist so I say everything's politics
well then let's make things not politics
let's do things that are in politics or
let's make music that isn't politics
music you know or or it is like you're
gonna come to a skate shop with a big
old Gadsden flag flying above it
marxists win if everything's politics
I'll put it this way to be that way true
we'll have a big old Gadsden flag on our
skate shop but when you walk through
those doors underneath that Gadsden flag
you're going to get a premium quality
pro skateboard gear
for cheaper good coffee too with coffee
yeah you get a free coffee with every
board yeah coffee heavy cream included
because we're keto yep but why would why
would any mother father or skater be
like I'd rather go to that woke skate
shop where everything's 50 more
expensive because I'm woke now they're
gonna be like look man dude the board's
aboard I can't afford it true and then
when they're riding around on a step on
step and find out board and they're woke
friends why are you riding Tim pulls
borlik because it costs 20 bucks dude
and it's pro quality yeah Shaq did a
very similar thing with sneakers that's
right because he talked about how a
mother came to him and was complaining
about how his sneakers were I think a
hundred dollars or 150 and that was
unaffordable so he then uh worked with
um I forgot what company he worked with
but he made his own shoe line and he
made sneakers twenty dollars and then he
was able to get a huge chunk of the
market and make a lot of people happy
and was able to sell a lot more shoes
than a lot of the other competitors that
he was going up against because he
decided to price them out fairly because
a lot of the times when you're paying
for a product you're paying for The
Branding you're paying for the marketing
you're paying for all the other bull
crap associated with it which is now
associated with the ESG social credit
score system which is meant to
indoctrinate you which is meant to of
course divide you and to of course
eventually conquer you but if you're
able to do the opposite of that let's do
it I'm in you know I don't have Disney
anymore oh Stefan Mulberry also did a I
want to shout him out because he was
around where I grew up he was a
basketball player he also did a very
similar thing he made uh his own
sneakers his own clothing line at a very
Avail affordable price compared to his
competitors so shouts out to Stefan
Mulberry
um awesome guy I don't have uh Disney
anymore because ever since the uyghur
Muslim Scandal that happened I said I
would never sign it back up so I had
already had a year subscription it
lapsed
but the thing is I don't I don't expect
people to cancel their Netflix their HBO
or whatever because people want
entertainment it's a normal thing people
buy we just need to create something to
compete with it so that people are like
I'd rather not watch that it is very
difficult it is very easy to open a
skate shop relative to starting a global
Media company with you know subscription
service to compute the likes of the 30
million or whatever Netflix subscribers
but that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm talking about doing so I think
the brick and mortar shop is
probably the faster route towards
building culture
you know we obviously with cast of
Castle tales in the inverted World pop
culture crisis we here at timcast are
working on creating media products it's
hard to do yeah it's it's hard to do
because
you know
with an online product let's say pop
culture crisis we need more we want we
want more people to watch that talk
about pop culture and stuff
and have that influence exist but this
is an Internet space meaning there's no
location you literally have to create
the audience with a physical location
you've got natural flow so for the
building we have now we open a coffee
shop revenue is basically guaranteed we
can afford to operate it and we can make
just enough money to keep it running
skate shop and everything as well and
then we can easily make more and keep
doing it replicate it all over the
country maybe even in other countries
and then have a space where when you
walk in to buy a coffee you look on the
TV and what do you see playing as you're
ordering a coffee it's lucrutkowski
ranting about Klaus Schwab imagine that
imagine there were a thousand coffee
shops and they were like as ubiquitous
as Starbucks but instead of going in and
seeing CNN on TV you see Stephen Crowder
or stick sex and Hammer or Viva and
Barnes or middlemaga
yeah and then regular customers aren't
gonna they're gonna walk in and be like
oh what's this they're gonna be sipping
their coffee back oh that's cool and
that's how we gain access for more
people and more cultural spaces that's
the plan man yeah so maybe we'll
franchise it maybe that'll be the plan
and also competitions just like uh
skateboarding competition Stefan
Mulberry used to have basketball
competitions in Coney Island that I used
to play in and he would get the funds
from a lot of his uh bigger kind of
companies than the cheaper sneakers he
would kind of give out there and then
pay for this uh competition pay for this
larger Festival you get you got free
sneakers you got free jerseys and he
would always come through the community
and give a lot of the stuff out and I
remember uh being a young kid in in
Brooklyn at the time being a part of
that thinking how cool that that someone
in the NBA is coming here and giving
back to the community uh more than all
these other people who of course
essentially sell out and forget where
they came from so uh uh you know Stefan
warberry was awesome shout out to Monica
I want to shout him out again because of
the impact he had on me playing
basketball in New York City
yeah I didn't know you played Hoops yeah
I I love basketball and that was a big
part of my life when I was very young
um and uh yeah it's it's a great way of
staying out of trouble especially in New
York City thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time